hey guys it's just Eid and today I'm
unboxing the new Animal Crossing
Nintendo switch I'm honestly really
excited about this but I initially when
this was first released I told myself
just saying you don't need this don't
get it don't buy it
so I missed the pre-order deadline and
then as the time was nearing I
definitely got FOMO and I went on eBay
and I did some things and that's where
we are today this is one of my favourite
games it is so much fun so the fact that
I was gonna pass on this incredible
Nintendo switch I'm not really sure what
I was thinking I think I was trying to
be a responsible adult and then I
remembered you're not Justine you're not
a responsible adult at all I know
there's been a lot of delays in other
countries because of all the things that
are happening right now so hopefully
some of you guys who did order this will
get it within a reasonable timeframe but
if not I feel like a lot of you guys
already do have switches so thankfully
well it's actually not thankfully the
game doesn't actually even come with
this console so if you did happen to
order this and you already do have a
Nintendo switch you can still play it
but I think one of the things that is up
in the air is how will you be able to
transfer your island to another Nintendo
switch I think eventually that is
something that obviously Nintendo is
gonna have to address depending on when
you're watching this video maybe they
already addressed it but from what I saw
online right now they have it yet either
way I'm very excited about this this
comes out on my birthday on March 20th
and it's crazy because I feel like the
last several years video games have come
out on my birthday so it really is one
of the best gifts I mean I could not
have asked for a better gift than this
to be released on my special day because
I will be probably still quarantine II
myself in my house which I think I'm
doing anyway
okay let's unbox
the box is beautiful everything is oh
look at the blue and the green perfect
colors
what of the great combination both of
those colors also look really great with
pink so here's the console itself so I
know this has been out for so long the
fact that this right here is a console
everything that you need is in here so
it's got a really cute little animal
crossing' design on the back Tyler if
you played this game before no well I
know what you're gonna be doing you're
gonna love it and then you're also gonna
be like what have I done what if I don't
like you you wake up in the morning and
you start playing because it's real time
like real time with like your yes
so like shops close if you don't get to
them in time it becomes a lifestyle okay
so we've got some of the usual goodies
we've got our little controller here to
put both of the joy columns together I
love the colored straps look at this the
blue and the green to correspond too
much controller to put them on and your
dock oh boy it's crazy because I've
really been loving the Nintendo switch
light because I really don't ever talk
and play games on my TV anymore look at
this oh it's really really really cute
maybe I can get somebody to like paint
my name right here like how cool would
that be
is it the shoe guy you were telling me
about him pink you can't come over
because we're all not a lot out of our
house and stuff
talk to you later talk to me later we're
more when things are back okay here's
our doc let's open up these joy Kahn's
oh boy look how pretty these look great
actually perfect because one of my joy
Kahn's just broke on my other Nintendo's
which I remember you can always mix and
match joy con colors so maybe I can like
pop a little pink one on ear here's the
little joy con attachments I love a
color matching of the little wrist
straps okay so here it is
I guess there's really not much else I
put this is it
I've already unboxed it now I gotta
transfer everything over from my old
switch what a great sound this is so
much bigger than the I just which light
it's so weird cuz I have playing that
for so long
okay so we've got our dock let's put
this switch in the puzzle has been
completed
he had this looks great I can't wait to
play this game like I've been thinking
about this
probably for I guess whenever the switch
originally first came out only they had
StreetPass would you guys be interested
in some animal crossing gameplay perhaps
if so give me a thumbs up and leave me
some comments below even if you don't
want it I'm probably gonna do it anyway
I'm definitely excited about this game
I've been kind of actively avoiding
watching any trailers or anything about
it other than the initial a little a
Nintendo Direct that they did before
because I just kind of want to go into
this as more of a surprise anyway I hope
you guys are staying safe out there I'm
gonna have to postpone my birthday party
so that means maybe y'all have a
birthday party vlog when
able to have it again or maybe I can
make a birthday party vlog by myself but
they look fat or I could have a live is
true I can livestream my birthday party
for myself oh this is gonna be so fun
okay I'm gonna go I'm gonna go set this
switch up now I'll see you guys later
I'm feel so weird everything is so weird
don't know how to feel
[Music]